hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast learning from the poal list
using big data approaches to embrace the
complexity of cancer I am Judy oror of
labroots we are delighted to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by
labroots we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or sub
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Dr Ken buto
has 30 plus years experience as a data
scientist formerly trained as a
geneticist and genomicist he develops
and applies it infrastructure and
analytic approaches to collect manage
manipulate and interrogate large complex
biomedical data sets as part of the
Human Genome Project his group undertook
pioneering uses of the internet in biom
medicine to create the human inheritance
map later while leading the National
Cancer institute's efforts in biomedic
informatics he launched efforts to
connect the global cancer Community he
is leading asu's Next Generation cyber
infrastructure effort creating a 21st
century multi- capability data science
research instrument designed to leverage
computational storage software and human
capital to complex problems in
biomedicine can receive received his ba
from Indiana University and an MS and
PhD from the University of
Pittsburgh thank you very much Judy for
the for the introduction and I want to
thank the audience for uh joining this
session um uh I look forward to uh
spending the time together and uh and uh
sharing with you a interesting work that
we're doing in my group uh in applying
Big Data approaches
uh to helping us understand uh and
embrace the complexity of
cancer as this group is more than aware
uh we're in the midst of a
transformation of the whole biomedical
Enterprise that
transformation uh is uh in the form of
personalized medicine personalized
medicine being targeting the right
getting medicines to the right
individual delivering the the Right Care
at the right time in the right place
this personalized medicine uh uh
transformation is at once Revolution uh
it it Embraces the very molecular nature
of an individual and their disease but
it's also Renaissance it returns us back
to uh a a previous time uh when
Physicians and Care delivery individuals
knew not only the characteristics of one
dis of one's disease but also knew the
characteristics of the person themselves
their preferences what were the
challenges in their life uh as well as
the the environment in which they worked
in uh lived in and the environment that
may dictate or change how their care may
be received or their care may be able to
be uh
delivered as this audience is more than
aware we're now more than 10 years into
this uh personalized medicine Revolution
shown on this slide is the is the uh uh
is the Breakthrough uh poster child
literally the cover story of
personalized medicine gleevac that at
the time was heralded as a a tremendous
revolution in how cancer was going to be
treated where drugs were driven by the
to specific individual characteristics
of the disease uh and had tremendous
success uh when
applied what we've learned though over
time and even in the earliest of Trials
is that these Wonder drugs while
miraculous literally watching tumors
Melt Away in a subset of individuals had
other challenges and continue to have
challenges associated with them for
instance we could see that uh that even
the best of the drugs uh did not work in
all individuals and we could see that
some individuals uh had almost immediate
failures we also saw that even uh those
that did appear to have responses uh
shortly uh and durable responses for as
we can see here measured in weeks
ultimately uh had their tumors come back
and sometimes respond almost at
catastrophic rates the suddenly instead
of failing gently uh the tumors would
actually return with a Vengeance uh so
while unequivocally there's an immediate
impact that occurs from treating uh
individual uh individual molecular
lesions uh with these marvelous new
drugs uh there's clearly something more
going on something more going on as to
why some folks don't respond why even
after folks respond
uh there continues to be uh uh ongoing
failure and ongoing and ultimately
complete failure of this new
intervention and the interventions only
lasting commonly for a matter of singled
digigit months at
best so what is going on well I think
the key thing to embrace is that cancer
uh as much as we would hope that it
could be due to perhaps a single
molecular
modification is in fact complicated so
what do I mean by complicated well as
this group knows cancer starts from
origin or originates in otherwise normal
cells those normal cells over time
accumulate multiple mutations forming in
some instances a for all intents and
purposes a new organ within an organ
those multiple mutations actually occur
not just a handful of them but there are
actually dozens to hundreds to in some
individuals thousands of mutations uh uh
not at all uncommon for there to be uh a
h 100 different mutations observed in
any given uh cancer that's analyzed at a
molecular level and more challenging and
pragmatic is that those hundreds of
mutations are not shared between two
different individuals so this mutational
profile occurs is relatively novel for
each individual Who develops
cancer over and above this mutational
profile clearly we can have changes that
occur at the DNA level specific
mutations that we can catalog but
alterations can occur at a level other
than specific changes to to a nucleic
acid or a DNA molecule they can occur By
changes in copy number uh they can occur
By changes that change the expression of
a gene while not changing the coding
sequence of the gene itself they can
occur through epigenetic modifications
changes that don't alter the nucleic
acids at all but instead change the
coding change the regulatory framework
uh by which genes are expressed and
genes are uh uh and genes manifest their
products uh they can occur uh through
the newly uh exciting field of micro
rnas other RNA class molecules that
modify the the behavior of otherwise
normal or uh the rest of the protein uh
coding genome and lastly there's
modifications that can occur in cancer
cells over and above uh the specifics uh
related to the proteome they can occur
through other biochemical uh methods and
processes we also know that cancer
requires multiple changes in fundamental
processes to manifest uh shown on this
slide as we can see those key processes
such as growth factor Independence
evading apotosis tiir maintenance cell
cycle regulation and
angiogenesis uh so for more than a
decade uh the seminal paper by Hannah
Han and Weinberg clearly indicated that
cancer required a cell to evade a whole
variety of control mechanisms but what's
emerged in the decades since this was
postulated was the recognition that
these are not single Gene phenomena but
in fact are products of complex networks
uh that growth factor Independence or
tier maintenance actually requires a
whole collection of interacting genes in
order for one to uh be able to manifest
cancer moreover what's been observed is
as we look at each of these individual
processes we can see that one
individual's mutation May Target one of
the genes in a different process in one
of these processes but if we look at
another individual it's a different set
of genes that are mutated and yet
another individual would have another
collection of genes that are modified so
all this is occurring just simply at the
sematic level for cancer over and above
the somatic level of cancer we also have
our genetic constant tion the inherited
variation ranging anywhere each of us
has one to five million differences in
the DNA that we inherited from our
mother versus the DNA We inherited from
our father and it's been well
demonstrated that that genetic
Constitution can change the processes of
angiogenesis uh the basic fundamentals
of your cellular matrix or your immune
response or also importantly can modify
filter change or eliminate the effects
of chemicals viruses hormones Nutrition
a whole series of exogenous factors so
to be fair our cancer it's not only
complicated it's very complicated and
the point I'm trying to make is that we
ignore this complexity at our Peril and
almost assuredly we now know that it is
that complexity that drives the the
differences in responses and the
refractory nature of individuals who are
developing cancer uh who are failing or
ultimately developing resistance to
their
treatments uh this complexity is now
being further embraced ironically from
the folks that initially had hoped and
were positing uh the reductionist
Paradigm that cancer could or might be
simple that if we just simply understood
or knew uh the handfuls of mutations
that would occur uh that that we would
be able to overcome cancer so even the
uh pillars of uh this Simplicity
Paradigm folks like Weinberg who had
suggested the original basic simple set
of processes are now indicating that if
we're going to make progress in cancer
we're going to have to figure out how to
embrace this true underlying complexity
so I would actually argue that the way
we Embrace this complexity is in part to
take a page from the poal lists uh our
current point of view is that if we just
focus sharply enough and deeply enough
On Any Given set of points or a specific
set of points that will understand
cancer what the pointless realized is
that in fact to truly get a rich
colorful tapestry what we needed to do
was interconnect and combine points uh
and that by combining individual points
there would be emergent properties novel
colors novel perceptions that would make
a painting Rich understandable and
convey a message this is exactly what
nature is doing uh as it is creating the
complex fabric that is our biologic
framework but also what is being
disrupted in cancer so what we recognize
is if we actually embrace this
complexity look at the emergent
properties we can see that those point
Point actually do have a coherence that
as we start to assemble them more and
more present a picture and as that
picture starts to emerge we can actually
see the broader story and through that
story then can better understand how
cancer manifests and more importantly
hopefully how to intervene uh to change
it uh to change its
course so cancer uh to be more technical
is a complex adaptive system so what do
I mean by a complex adaptive system well
it evolves over time as we just showed
in the previous set of cartoons it has
adaptive Behavior so cancer today isn't
the same as cancer was yesterday and
more pragmatically it changes in
response to the environmental factors uh
that it's that it's confronting those
environmental factors may be its
cellular millu but it may also be the
inter inter ventions that we are taking
against it uh it has a very large number
of elephant or of elements uh element
elephants may be the correct Freudian
slip here an elephant collection of
elements that defy conventional
descriptions and in fact it's not only
impractical but it's not clear that we
can use Simple mathematical descriptions
of how the system would work the past is
co-responsible for the present so where
you were makes a differences to where
you're going but I guess I would say
most importantly among the core complex
adaptive system properties is it has
emergent properties in other words the
whole is more than the sum of the parts
so if there's a key take-home lesson is
the recognition that we can't completely
understand cancer simply by taking it
apart and looking at it at a piece at a
time it there are properties that emerge
by the combination of particular factors
and components uh key to understanding
how a complex adaptive system works is
it's critically dependent the pieces of
a system are dependent on resources and
most importantly on information uh and
the transfer of information within the
system which brings us then to the
recognition that cancer is information
Laden and a big data problem to
understand how the system is working we
have to know that information and the
information flows between the individual
components well Big Data what what is
Big Data perhaps one of the uh most
commonly used word I don't think you can
open a newspaper today without somebody
talking about the power and the
revelations uh that emerge from Big Data
uh and what folks are doing with big
data well big data definitionally is um
big uh it's large volume and in
particular when we're in the
personalized medicine criteria uh we
actually recognize if we're doing genome
sequencing or evaluation of the whole
molecular profile we're looking at three
times 10 to the 9th base pairs we're
looking at a big volume of data but it's
also clear that big data especially
meaningful use of Big Data not only
Embraces the volume of the data but it
also increases the variety of the data
as well as the velocity and that's the
interconnection and changes in data over
time so for us to truly Embrace cancer
is a big data problem we need to manage
large volumes understand its diversity
and figure out how it changes and
sometimes rapidly changes over time so
clearly The genome is one source of the
big data in in the cancer problem but
over and above the genome definition the
molecular definition we also know that
there are rich collections of data from
the phenome and when I say phenome in
this instance I mean the clinical
characteristics personal characteristics
uh that describe who an individual is
and what they have experienced over and
above their uh inherited and or acquired
genome and over and above that there's
the exposome that's important this is is
the vast array of of of environmental
inputs the components that are all
around us that set the context for what
defines your phenome and for what your
genome is reacting
to the phenome data comes from many many
different places there's a diverse types
of phenome data the clinical
observations Laboratories Imaging
registry bios specimens and even
reference data and of distributed in
many many different sources so one of
the challenges of doing big data in biom
medicine is embracing its large
collection of sources and distributed
places of and both its large collection
of sources and large collections of
types one of the key pieces of emerging
big data that in many ways will rival uh
the size of the data associated with
genomes is Imaging data as we get more
and more sophisticated in noninvasive
ways of characterizing molecular State
and individual Constitution uh Imaging
shown here is just the uh Transit of a
drug through an individual and seeing
where it originally is reposited where
it goes uh and then where it ends up uh
these images any one of them are as
large in terms of uh computer storage
size as a genome but are are remarkably
powerful in describing a
phenotype but this is just the beginning
we're we're at the precipice of
revolutionary new data resources that
will be of equally large volume uh
earlier this year was launched or
announced Google's attempt to create
smart contact lenses these are lenses
that would uh are essentially little
molecular monitors that you would wear
in your eye that would have the ability
to uh continuously monitor any number of
biologic entities uh again creating a
large data feed that changes rapidly
over time both of uh volume and velocity
uh but also variety because these
different chips will ultimately be tuned
to manage your a whole collection of
dynamic variables that again will dwarf
uh the genome in its size and this but
one of a whole series of examples of
things that are exploding on the
monitoring front show here are just a
handful of them uh that are on that
would actually not only monitor your
physiologic state your phenome uh but
would also allow you to manage and and
capture information on your expose Zone
the environmental entities that to date
has been quite commonly a black box
other than well-described well-known
risk factors like cigarette smoking or
some other exogenous Force these are
going to allow us to have much deeper
collection of information of what one's
lifetime experiences are related to the
environment that one lives
in so how do we take this data and
convert it into evidence because at the
end of the day data may be large and may
be useful but it doesn't actually
translate into anything that's
actionable until we change it from data
to information and the key variable in
changing uh data to information is by
understanding the relationship between
individual data the specific data items
so when we understand map or derive the
relationship between data points we
start to have information but at the end
of the day real evidence is more than
just information it's evidence is
information in context uh where we Now
understand the pattern in and increase
the connectedness and what we're really
interested in in is not just even
information information is valuable uh
but the true actionable information is
knowledge which requires us to further
connect and understand the pattern of
data as well as its relationship to
other data
points so what I want to spend a few
minutes for is talking a little bit
about what we're currently doing uh in
my lab and others uh in addressing this
large scale data class opportunities and
challenges and how we're going about
trying to convert data into information
and information into knowledge what I
want to start with is approaches that
are being taken to discover the
relationships the first step from
starting with big data and converting it
into
information so uh to borrow a page from
The Graduate and what Young Benjamin was
Council the when people say where should
I look you know what should I look and
what should I be worrying about if we
want to know who's on the leading
bleeding edge of doing novel work in
discovering relationships I would point
you simply to Google so most of us are
familiar and are almost addicted to
Google I can it's times difficult for me
to picture how I used to do either my
personal or professional life before I
had ready access to Google to answer all
my questions but one of the ways that
Google is able to be such a powerful
entity in providing critical information
is that it constantly is building the
relationships between information
between data to create information I'm
sure everyone has I has at some point in
time uh in doing a search marveled a bit
at what they call anticipatory search uh
where as you start to type in a
particular set of words Google starts to
anticipate what kind of search you may
want to be doing that comes uh from them
understanding the connections uh and the
relationships between different pieces
of data so that they can use that in
meaningful ways uh as you might guess
the metaphor as we then move into uh
biomedicine genetics genomics and cancer
what we want to be doing is doing with
uh biomedical data the same sort of
understanding of relationships of all
those individual pois points
the same way that Google does with the
data that's present in its large query
database another example of this uh in a
different set of analytics and different
set of approaches is what Amazon does uh
I'm sure all of us have had the
experience when we've decided to
purchase an Amazon book suddenly being
uh brought to our attention uh a series
of additional books that we might be
interested in that to be honest with you
quite commonly do find things that would
be of interest and again this is
leveraging analytics that look at the uh
that discover the relationship between
large collections of disconnected points
uh what they do is uh look for
nonobvious relationship analysis through
doing a process called non-obvious
relationship analysis look for and find
uh nonrandom patterns that are are
useful for making predictions uh and
that are useful in driving uh what sort
of actions you might take or
facilitating the actions that you might
want to
take all of this is actually part of an
an emerging New Field the fourth
Paradigm science which stands on the
shoulders of of of previous paradigms
the previous three that started with
observational built into experimental
and then drove to uh manipulative uh
data science uh or paradigms of science
what fourth Paradigm science does is
complement data generating science with
data driven science and I I'll give you
a in the traditional definition of
fourth Paradigm science they would say
hypothesis testing science as opposed
the datadriven science actually I I
refuse to acknowledge that datadriven
science doesn't test hypothesis uh
partially I guess I would posit that
given the number of fields that I've
been doing dat driven science actually
for not only decades at some sense
centuries if we look at astronomy
physics economics climate and and now
hopefully genomics U but the reason I
would actually argue that data driven
science can also be hypothesis testing
science is I I would pait that we don't
talk about Newton's uh good ideas of
planetary motion we talk about Newton's
laws of planetary motion and to the best
best of my knowledge there has not yet
been a successful experiment where one
has actually moved or realigned a planet
to test what would actually happen if
you moved a planet uh what is done
instead is pre constructing hypothesis
that then can be tested with the with
the additional sets of observations or
additional sets of data examinations or
collections that allow one to ask and
answer questions in a completely
datadriven space without actually
formally manipulating the system per se
uh but again datadriven science can and
I think will be is perceived to be as
rigorous in the future uh as the
previous three paradigms of
science part of this is driven by the
unreasonable effectiveness of data this
is a paper that has driven much of the
internet Commerce Universe uh over the
last decade uh by the recognition that
large volumes of data have inherently
captured in them information and
knowledge that can be actually
actionable and that if we Harvest that
information uh uh we can actually do
interesting and important
things uh as this group is probably
aware there's a whole multi-billion
dollar interest stre now tied around the
harvesting of data converting it to
information and trying to harness
knowledge uh for instance it was just
announced yesterday that uh uh that uh
Facebook now La announced its third
quarter uh profit statements and uh has
made more than a billion dollars in
advertising from directing uh or
capturing and translating the data it
collects into information that it uses
to drive people uh to particular uh
particular purchases or to particular
ads all of this work to date is really
all around uh the what was a question
posed uh uh almost almost a century ago
almost a century and a half ago uh by uh
by John Waker one of the famous Moguls
of of Commerce at the time uh Pioneer in
uh merchandising and in sales uh and the
question that he framed was that that he
spends half the money he spends on
Advertising is a waste and he doesn't
couldn't figure out which half and so
what the new data entrepreneurs are
doing in advertising uh is figuring out
who should get what advertising and
targeting that advertising to those
individuals uh I might suggest that this
is completely isomorphic with the
personalized medicine agenda it's
actually taking information that we
would know about
individuals uh and then directing it and
then directing our interventions to uh
those individuals just the same as the
ads are doing uh as I indicated there's
a multi-billion doll industry doing this
today and and uh one of the pioneers of
that Jeff hamacher uh who was one of the
first individuals at Facebook that was
charged with figuring out why there was
adoption at certain places and now
that's transformed into
advertising um indicated that the what
we're doing is is again driven by a a
mercantilistic point of view we we're
clearly are leveraging that framework
but unfortunately most of the bright
Minds addressing these problems to date
are more around how do we get people to
click on ads than how do we get people
to respond to Next Generation uh
therapeutic interventions that said
uh young uh young Mr Hamaker has voted
with his feet and is now left uh
Facebook uh and uh and the other big
data company that he helped co-found
Cloud era which is uh provides the
commercial supported Big Data Frameworks
that that we and other groups are using
uh has now moved and is challenging his
talents is channeling his talents to
solving important problems at Health as
an assistant professor in genetics and
genomics at Mount cyani Hospital in New
York so uh Jeff and others are then
leading a transformation as to how do we
bring this data science point of view uh
this large scale big data point of view
uh into the healthcare
Arena uh and are also driving U what we
hope to be uh an attraction to uh the
next generation of young scientists to
recognize that data scientists at least
if we believe what's written in the
Harvard Business Review is the sexiest
job of the 21st century so those young
people who uh might be participating in
this call I I challenge you that if
you're looking for some high impact sexy
new job uh I can only give you two words
data
scientist so we at ASU are also uh uh
voting with our feet so Our intention uh
is to try to harness this tsunami of
data that's starting to emerge both in a
molecular and clinical setting and
figure out a way to process this uh and
convert this data into information and
information into knowledge and we're
doing this through the creation of a of
a of a first generation data science
research platform or research instrument
uh in our Parliament called a Next
Generation cyber capability or the
ngcc so what is is this ngcc data
science research platform well basically
I think it's what we're attempting to do
is do for data science uh what the
Hubble telescope uh has done for
astronomy give a common large scale
platform that uh will facilitate doing
things that one just simply couldn't do
by themselves without the use of
important instruments or the large hron
collider in physics or the Mars over for
the planatory exploration Community
having an instrument that would allow us
to uh capture and manipulate uh data in
unprecedented
ways our ngcc data science instrument
actually is a novel computational
platform that brings together a unique
collection of physical capacity ultra
high bandwidth networks 100 gigabit
ethernet which essentially means that uh
your data arrives instantaneously
regardless of where it might sit in your
computer or nationally or
internationally it has large scale
storage we have more than two pedabytes
of uh of storage uh we have multiple
flavors of computation so we have uh
Traditional High Performance Computing
more than a thousand uh high performance
Computing you know it's a more than
4,000 GPU based processors we have a
large shared memory framework as well as
the new physical
configurations necessary to support the
Big Data framework uh that underpins
Google or that underpins Facebook or
underpins Twitter uh the the Hadoop
largescale Big Data framework uh of
physical constraint of physical
capabilities as well as then The Logical
software necessary to support that over
and above those logical capabilities and
applications that then run in this
framework we also very actively manage
the data about data metadata data that
allows us to know what data we have as
well as to to every time we derive or or
obtain a relationship between data types
to store that so that our Web of
Knowledge our interconnections between
the data gets richer and richer every
time we perform an analysis and of
course even though this is a data
science instrument an elemental piece of
this a piece that can't literally be
separated away it's more than just
hardware and software it's people so to
be able to execute this framework we
need a whole collection of people that
know how to uh use both the physical
infrastructure know how to configure it
manage it and interconnect it as well as
that know how to do the the new data
science analytics the uh new machine
learning approaches uh and the new
collections of analytic techniques that
were being appli that are being applied
in the other sectors of the economy but
are still somewhat uh underdeveloped in
the biomedical
sphere so shown here is all of the
pieces coming together save the humans
where we see the physical pieces
connected to the logical pieces that
that have manage context that perform
the analysis that let us do transactions
and
manipulations uh and then you can also
see on the very uh on the very right
hand side of the figure you can see then
the intention of this is to fill this
with a very large collection of various
forms of data case Report Form
instruments electronic health records
molecular data and all sorts of data
that we will then on in an on in manner
mind for relationships so that we can
create data transform data into
information and hopefully provide
context so that we can generate
knowledge our early efforts at ASU are
turning uh this uh data research
instrument toward a growing worldwide
problem the problem of diabesity and
just per chance those of you who are uh
are uh spelling jihadists on this is
actually is not a typo it's meant to be
combining the emerging trends of obesity
and diabetes uh which is a new epidemic
that's epidemic that's occurring not
just in the developed world as we might
speculate but also in the developing
world so for those of you who aren't
familiar uh there's an explosion of
obesity and diabetes worldwide shown on
this slide is uh
highlights partially what one might
expect you can see in the dark purple
the places that are not surprisingly H
are not necessarily surprisingly high in
the rate of obesity and diabetes North
America uh Western Europe um but what I
think is interesting on this slide and
that's emerging in worldwide Trends is
the observation that this explosion
isn't only happening in the developed
world but it's also happening in the
develop in the developing world so I
point you to India uh which also has an
exploding collection of obesity and
diabetes uh not as evident on this
particular figure but if we look in the
industrial the urban areas of China
Shanghai Beijing other areas such as
that we can also see
explosions uh uh and near epidemic
levels of diabetes and obesity so
shortly this is going to be a
worldwide
epidemic so what we know as a community
this this is not new knowledge is that
obesity drives one to diabetes
cardiovascular disease liver disease and
it's been known among epidemiologists
for a long time that obesity also drives
cancer but this has been but this but
relatively still underappreciated with
the cancer Community now why do we get
so many outcomes from obesity well shown
on this will acknowledge unreadable
slide is a is a is a map that shows all
of the factors that drive both the
development of obesity as well as the
outcomes associated with obesity now in
the very center of this figure would be
components that most of you are are
already familiar with we quite commonly
talk about that obesity is simply a
product of calories inverses this
calorie out but what one understands is
that the there are many many factors
that influence that very simple equation
that obesity is simply calories in
calories out and many many factors then
that drive whether in fact one develops
disease and it is still almost
completely unknown as to who will
develop what diseases so shown in this
next slide is the complex collection of
interacting components that drive
obesity and its related outcomes so who
the origins as well as the outcomes of
obesity are driven by
physiology uh by psychology uh by uh
physical activity uh by the economy by
the built environment all of these
pieces are important contributors and
are pieces of the puzzle that we need to
better
understand so as I mentioned it's been
well known that obesity is a contributor
to uh to cancer risk um but this has
been recently been reinforced by a a new
study that was published a couple months
ago in the Lancet uh that showed that
body mass index increases the risk of of
a large number of cancers shown on this
slide are are the top five uh or six
cancers that excuse me the top five
cancers that have the greatest impact uh
which obesity has the greatest impact in
altering
risk what I want to focus us on one of
the members of this list uh
hepatocellular carcinoma or liver cancer
and what you'll hear me posit here is
that are we at risk of having liver
cancer hypocellular carcinoma or HCC
become the lung cancer of the current
and future generation
uh much the same as smoking drove lung
cancer uh rates for the previous
generation uh starting approximately the
with the onset of large scale smoking uh
during the Advent of World War II are we
seeing that in fact liver cancer may be
similarly associated with obesity uh and
will we have similar epidemics in the
future as we move
forward so why do I focus on this why
might I make such a dire or cautionary
prediction one is that liver cancer HCC
is one of only two cancers that has been
consistently increasing in incidence
over the last four decades um the other
cancer well most other cancers have
either remained stable or reduced in
incidents liver cancer and pancreatic
cancer both cancers associated with fat
and obesity have shown increases and
shown here is that over the last 40
years the rate of liver cancer has
almost doubled uh and it's an equal
opportunity cancer risk factor all
groups uh all racial groups all ethnic
groups are showing a similar sort of
doubling in the incidence of liver
cancer what's remarkable that's changing
or one of the factors changing is those
of us with textbook knowledge of liver
cancer say well it's all attributable to
hepatitis to the infection of hepatitis
viruses both c and b and alcoholism
which clearly hepatitis viruses still
have remarkably High odds ratios but uh
in current uh Western countries and in
the United States in specific we can see
that actually what's the major cause of
liver cancer in the United States now is
diabetes and obesity so diabesity now
are the major causes of liver cancer in
the United States a remarkable shift uh
in the exposures the exposome components
driving the particular
disease so why is this the case well
just very briefly um we as evolutionary
organisms were not welld designed to
live in a fatri calorie Rich environment
uh given that the liver is a place where
uh the major metabolisms occur where an
energy and all sorts of metabolism
processes take place uh evolutionally
we're designed to uh differentially
store fat in our liver because it's the
best and easiest place for it to be
mobilized when necessary so when one
actually develops uh obesity one's liver
accumulates large collections of fat and
that fat actually as you can see in a
picture here uh not only
disrupts uh the basic uh configuration
but actually interferes with the
fundamental functioning of the liver
which then starts a whole process of um
Auto attack against one's liver uh that
generates hepatitis fibrosis therosis
and in some individuals uh ultimately
liver
cancer so we've been interested in
trying to start to get our arms around
uh understanding uh
what's driving this process and have
been started our efforts uh in diabesity
in looking at inherited DNA variation
partially because it's the key invariant
piece uh that we can track over an
individual's Lifetime and I've been
attempting to understand both the
origins of the morbidities associated
with Obed obesity but in particular the
origins of liver cancer and see if we
can predict who is likely to develop Li
liver cancer uh given uh the uh the
appropriate
exposures so our approach to doing this
has been by mapping phenotype to
underlying biologic process now
historically there's been a variety of
ways that this has been done through
transmission Maps a work I did actually
very early in my career through family
studies we'd look at an inheritance of
risk uh more recently there's been much
interest in somatic based Gene
signatures it's driven much of what we
see in the uh cancer genome anas class
projects but what's also emerging as an
important metaphor is Network
interaction signatures so as I mentioned
at the onset of the talk in talking
about Cancer's complexity what we
recognize is cancer arises through
multiple mutations and alterations
distributed among a whole collections of
genes that under that are are occurring
in a variety of biologic processes so
we've been looking at how do we use
Network work interaction signatures in
order to find underlying molecular bases
uh that describe phenotypes so we've
been doing network analysis of
constitutional variation our Focus has
been using novel Big Data tools derived
by uh my colleague Rosemary Braun when
she worked with me when I was at the
National Cancer Institute uh that allows
us to use uh the biologic networks or if
you're a big data scientist you would
say doing graph an analysis that's one
of the ways that Facebook and Google
create those complex queries or the way
Amazon knows what products you would
want to do it sort of creates the graphs
of interactions that drive and help
explain how people act we're trying to
do the same thing both deriving and
leveraging those graphs those biologic
networks in understanding specific
phenotypes so we did an early study
looked at liver cancer in almost a
thousand individuals but more
importantly again in a big data context
looked at more than two million variants
that were identified across those almost
thousand o o almost over a thousand
individuals in this what we saw was not
surprisingly individual points the
poteris points of view uh interestingly
when we say significant genes these
genes were were shown to be marginally
significant not unlike what we would see
in a traditional GW study but when we
look now at the graphs the biologic
networks of which these genes are
members of what we could see is we would
get whopping significant just
astronomically uh significant uh
collections of networks graphs that seem
to be distinguishing individuals who
were destined to go on to develop
therosis and liver cancer uh and
discriminate those
and discriminating it from those who did
not uh shown here is just a a technical
graph for those who are interested in
the underlying statistics of of how this
pathway of Distinction analysis shows
how uh we could see differences between
the individuals who went on to develop
liver cancer uh versus individuals who
uh did not have liver cancer so we're
now applying this type of analysis not
only to liver cancer but the precursor
phenotypes as well as using these types
of analysis across what is literally
hundreds of terabytes it's estimated at
its completion that there'll be more
than 2.5 pedabytes of data Associated
for instance with the cancer genom Atlas
project we're now using these types of
Big Data graph analysis approaches to
try to find important signals uh that
were
previously unidentified or were of such
small effect that they were diff they
were difficult to act
on so the other area that we've been
exploring is how do we not only find
these relationships and leverage them
but then understand the patterns and
there's a variety of ways that we can
understand the patterns uh and in
particular as I mentioned in a complex
adaptive system these patterns change
over time so uh our strategy is to
capture component understanding known
relationships either from the literature
or
uh derived relationships similar to what
I just described for liver cancer uh and
uh or from our data science
approaches and then join these at the
interface uh and either approach them
through a combination of uh differential
equations uh combined with uh biomedical
simulations where we actually take this
information and now look for the
emergent properties as we combine the
reductionist components to see if the
pieces behave in combination the way
that they would be predicted to behave
by themselves so this is done through
simulation techniques shown here is
actually an open-source public
simulation tool I realized the the URL
the crediting URL is on the next version
of the slide uh but what we can do is by
in placing in simple rules we can in
this instance look at cancer develop
this is a cancer simulation from
colleagues at Northwestern
University uh where my colleague uh
Rosemary bran is now and what they do in
this is just take simple patterns of
these simple observations and watch in
this instance a tumor develop over time
and as you can see on this Progressive
collection of diagrams as it not only
grows but metastasized so the little red
blob uh that one can see on the uh right
side of the diagram here
uh is the metastatic lesion that's grown
out of the original primary lesion but
what's fun important and illustrative
about doing these simulations is that we
can then manipulate specific variables
within the collection of facts that we
have and see what would be the influence
so in this overly simplified example we
show what would happen if you actually
had some sort of intervention that would
have the capacity to kill off these
transitionary cells the cells that were
in place as the cell as the tumor
metastasized and what we can see is the
act of killing those unless one was
completely effective uh is insufficient
and you still get a metastic lesion
similarly we could look at what's the
effect if we actually kill the moving
stem cell as opposed to the
transitionary cells and we can
see interestingly importantly we get
with rid of the metastatic lesion which
may be important in cancer uh because
normally it's metastasis uh that kill
one in cancer but you can see that has
no effect on the original tumor and
given our models of heterogeneity may
only be a matter of time all of what
we're seeing with our current targeted
therapies before a new collection of of
cells or migratory stem cells have the
capacity to develop lastly what we can
see is what would happen if we kill off
the originating stem cells and what we
can see is we would then be able to kill
the progenitor cells in a tumor uh but
may not have any impact on a metastatic
lesion so all of these allow us to do in
uh in silico experiments that allow us
to explore different intervention
strategies or different assumptions in
the model so this is meant to be
cartoonishly simple what our group is
doing is again using our NGC CC platform
uh that has uh this uh thousands of gpus
game uh processing units were
essentially creating simulations uh
video game class uh uh scenarios where
we can put in and change the underlying
molecular rules see how cancer behaves
and how work progresses shown here is
work done by one of my colleagues
working on these simulations that showed
by creating simple sets of rules tools
we could uh and this is an immune
simulation we could by creating
particular classes of immune cells we
could successfully generate uh and
maintain uh the thymus gland and chart
how immune responses would be dictated
through uh this framework so we're
currently doing this uh with a variety
of different cancers uh trying to
capture their basic sets of rules in
computable form and then perform these
in silico experiments to evaluate the
internal consistency of the data uh as
well as to evaluate uh how well and to
Target how we might create novel
intervention strategies or better
understand how either existing
interventions are working or not
working so uh in summary I guess I want
to close by uh emphasizing that we are
at this exciting new Pro precipice of
personalized medicine in fact early
early efforts are underway and having
success uh but what we actually
recognize and what's emerging uh is that
in personalized medicine uh we need to
measure both molecular State and diverse
clinical information for it to truly
have an impact uh personalized medicine
uh and cancer in specific is a big data
problem that we can get novel insights
by managing complexity through modular
models and that we can find these both
modular models uh and relationships and
connections through a an ongoing use of
emerging data science tools many of
which are developing outside of biom
medicine and we believe we have early
evidence that through the application of
these data science approaches that we
can get novel findings uh that are even
existing in large scale data that may
have already been published and left uh
and find new and important insights by
examining those so uh with that said I'd
like to thank you all and now move into
the question and answer portion of our
talk uh and certainly invite I put up on
the last screen here my email address uh
we're interested in working with and
collaborating with any groups that are
interested in diving into the data
science Waters to exploring cancer and
other complex disease uh but what I
would do is actually open the floor to
questions um and and and invite the
audience if you have uh questions to
please submit them in the Q&A box uh and
I will then uh answer them in turn as
they come about so uh please feel free
to uh submit questions uh if you have
them uh and uh I will take them in time
so I'll start with uh I'll start with a
question that's coming how can cancer
data be collected and stored safely uh
in a developing country uh I think an
excellent and important question and I
my point of view is that the one of the
powerful components of of of these new
data platforms is that they work quite
commonly on devices uh that are already
uh present in uh many developing uh
developing countries smart smartphone
platforms uh personal Computing
platforms and part of our efforts we're
actually already collaborating with
colleagues for instance in India uh to
deploy relatively simple tools that
certainly allow us to collect the
clinical information uh and to partner
with Cutting Edge institutions that have
the capacity to generate the the new
generation molecular characterization
but thank you uh very interesting and
important
question um are there other questions
that I might be able to ask or or that
others want to ask or answer or would
like to have answered got a couple
minutes left yet
um any other questions that the uh
audience would like to
submit um the URL I was asked what is
the URL for the model growth tumor uh
let me go back and I will tell you
again I'll put it up on the screen as
well as read it to you all so the URL is
um
um is c c or HTTP or htpp
col
C.N Northwestern
edu slet logo slm
models SL run. CGI question mark tumor
with a capital t.
7574 uh and again you all would have
access to these slides uh you can
actually if you can get it by me reading
it uh you should be able to get it from
the slides uh and to be honest if you go
if you get to just the C C.N
northwestern.edu
netlogo website uh you'll be able to see
the whole library of models that have
been generated using these simple agent
systems uh to support uh the uh to
support the generation of uh particular
models let me see if there's other
questions
um so uh I have a question as to how
does one go from being a data scientist
has worked in a commercial venue to a
biomedical application uh I think part
of what's emerging right now and
certainly what we're interested in our
model at ASU is through collaboration so
we're both number one recruiting into
our program individuals who have data
science or or those classes of
backgrounds from other settings uh to be
uh brought into our programs and be
trained by our medicine but what we're
also doing is partnering with
organizations uh that are have expertise
perhaps in fraud detection or figuring
out how to drive Web Clips and helping
bringing giving them access to
biomedical data so that they can apply
their algorithms and insights and
conversely uh also uh uh bringing their
tools into our environment so that they
can use our research platform so I think
there's a variety of approaches and
certainly if you're I certainly would
welcome anyone who's interested in
exploring these opportunities with us
specifically to drop me an
email um another question for clinicians
and scientists who are interested in
developing data science skills can you
recommend courses and textbooks so the
good news is is there's a a whole series
of emerging open-source class tools from
a number of the folks that um um that
develop the big dat data tools uh that
talk about how to create for instance uh
I mentioned Hadoop is the one of the
Prime platforms it's use that tell you
how to create a Hadoop framework uh and
or run machine learning tools uh that
would allow you to do particular
components um some of these groups even
I know one of the uh groups that
provides these platforms for instance
map R literally
mappr provides a a Down loadable piece
of software that you can put on your
personal computer uh and play with to uh
manipulate these specific tools what I
would actually argue to date though
there is not many ranching activities I
I showed the one uh document that that
was provided by the O'Reilly publishing
group that talks about how big data is
moving into health care so I'd point you
to the O'Reilly group that's publishing
papers uh and is very much involved with
g generating books in this but there
haven't been a lot of books Andor formal
papers yet one of the niches that we're
hoping to actually work with is to start
creating the bridges between these
communities okay another question is
there any possibility of an online
molecular recognition of cancer caused
by metabolites the short answer is I
think all of these things are on the
precipice so today there is not any such
tool but what would argue is what we
will be able to do by having creating
the same sort of profile matching that's
done you know instantly on Google or
Facebook or Yahoo uh when they're doing
ad matching once we start to build and
understand these relationships we would
be able to do um uh a whole large
collection of U of types of algorithms
that would be smartphone class apps that
I would actually argue will be
transformational in our biomedical
Arena uh another question are there
large Medical Data publicly available so
the short answer to that question is
there are beginning to be um much of the
large public much of the large Medical
Data not surprisingly uh is tied up for
in some instances human subjects
concerns uh and for others uh uh hyp
concerns about uh under what
circumstances it could or should be
shared with or without consent um there
are there are now
emerging uh Consortium and
collaborations like Pet's pop mednet
that would allow people to ask questions
against uh the Cornet group will have
more than a hundred million lives
covered under it and would allow you to
get summary class information on uh on
Medical Data uh there's also a movement
of foot from the pharmaceutical industry
uh to release data for research purposes
uh largely unrestricted for research
purposes from the comparator arms of
their trials uh so this is Project data
sphere and again these are large scale
databases that would have uh Rich
detailed well-controlled information on
uh essentially the standard of care
which is what drives clinical
trials okay any other
questions all right out wait a minute or
so more um I would suggest that just for
those of you uh who are interested the
presentation will be online uh if you
want to go back and revisit uh I'd also
remind folks if they're interested in
CME credits that uh this lecture is
eligible for CME credit uh and those who
would view the lecture online would have
the ability to submit questions uh uh
through email uh later on asynchronously
later on so with that I will uh say
thank you for your participation and
attendance uh I very much enjoy the
opportunity to share the the work we're
doing and the the uh Next Generation
opportunities would welcome individuals
who are interested in further
conversation further collaboration and
exploration
uh to uh join in and share in uh and
drop me a note uh but with that said I
will uh uh say thank you and uh uh end
this particular lecture so thank you
very
much